hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
why variants matter NGS bioinformatics
simplified for oncology and virology
presented by dr. Conde Carmack and dr.
Ahmed Mahmud I'm Suzy Valdez of laborat
and I will be your moderator for today's
event
we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
groups the leading scientific social
networking website provider of virtual
event and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning today's event
is sponsored by Vela Diagnostics Vela
Diagnostics is a worldwide supplier of
integrated life sciences and diagnostic
solutions that help provide customers
with valuable mark molecular information
from scientists striving to make
research advances and technicians
reporting the information necessary to
identify monitor and treat diseases
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this presentation is
interactive we want to hear from you
questions comments and even answers can
be submitted via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your screen we'll try
to get to everyone but if not we will
make sure to follow up with you by email
you can also enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of this slide window
if you cannot hear or see the
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q and a button at the
lower left this is an educational
webinar and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinars
over please click on the Cee button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I now like to
introduce our two presenters today first
dr. Ahmed Mahmud director of scientific
support for Vela Diagnostics dr. Mahmud
is a experienced scientist with both
hands on lab and bioinformatics
experience with degrees in molecular
biology and bioinformatics document mood
is currently the director of scientific
support Rosella Diagnostics
as well as the bioinformatics
application scientist dr. Millis team
handles all the technical wet labs and
implement ik support favela Diagnostics
QP TR and NGS workflows assistant with
pipeline creation for various NGS
workflows and robotic application
writings for automatic systems he has
experience developing the qPCR and
automated gene NGS workflows as well as
extensive experience in NGS data
analysis using multiple sequencing
platforms ESL positions in various areas
of biotech industries with institutions
such as jean DX Spitzer and Columbia
University Medical Center dr. Mehmet is
also an avid iOS developer creator of
computer apps gearing towards science
sector with him today is dr. Carmack our
second speaker dr. Conde Carmack is a
vice-president of precision oncology
adela delight Diagnostics dr. Carmack
received his PhD from the University of
Utah an experimental pathology and did
his postdoc in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
and in San Diego California in Mouse
genetics and molecular biology
he is the author or co-author of 23
peer-reviewed journals he wrote the
first paper on quantitative PCR and the
second paper on multiplex PCR he served
as a scientist reboard of Life
Technologies Inc and is an expert in
clinical PCR dr. Carmack was the
co-author on the first paper creating
human monoclonal antibodies for the
immunodeficient mice might serve as a
foundation for creation of the current
immune checkpoint blockade antibodies he
also served as a general manager of a
cancer genetic lab at Baylor College of
Medicine
before joining viola Diagnostics I will
now turn the presentation over to these
gentlemen dr. Carmack dr. Mahmood
welcome
much Susie for that introduction and
thank you everybody for mmm listening to
me and con visa presentation so let's
get started here our title is a wide
variance matter bioinformatics
simplified for oncology and biology so
what we hope to get out of this the
outline will be I'll give you a brief
introduction to next-generation
sequencing by informatics pipelines how
they apply to the field of biology and
then dr. Carmack will then go over the
oncology section so key learning
objectives here is to just understand
the basics of bio Matic says that apply
some extra motion sequencing and how we
take all of this sequencing data and
generate it into more meaningful
information second thing we wish to
achieve here is to have you understand
how the solutions that we have created
for biology and oncology help to make
your workflow in your processes a lot
more easier a lot more automated so
let's start with the biomat expounds
here so there are a few components of a
pipeline and they're usually attributed
to files first file that you'll see is
the fast queue file so the fast queue
file is very similar to its sister file
the fat a file which some of you may be
may have heard of so this is essentially
what a fast queue file will look like
you'll have your same information that
your fast
a file will have will have basically a
read a sequence identifier and your
sequence itself in this case for a fast
queue file you'll also add one more
component and that's of quality score so
this isn't really interpretable for a
human lien read and interpretation but
it is encoded in the ASCII format for
brevity
and it encodes a something called a
thread score so the flow Explorer is the
probability that your base has been
called an error right scores range from
zero all the way up you can you can
actually have read scores higher than 41
but basically we hire your phred score
be better your probability is that your
base has not been called in error so
that is a fast cue file format that fast
cue file will go into on a liner so
we're here now so the alignment phase
uses that fast cue file and a genomic
reference to align all those reads onto
the references and assign it a school so
there are different types of alignments
there's a global local and pairwise
alignment so global alignment is
basically taking the whole read and
trying to align that whole read to our
reference local alignment takes parts of
those parts of that read and tries to
align it to the reference and then
pairwise will take two reads and try to
align it to themselves to each other
there are a variety of different soft
open source software that can actually
do this for you some of them are
mentioned here BW is probably bigger
than both iya probably be more popular
versions out there what it's outputted
by this process is called a SAM file so
the fan file stands for sequence
alignment map file and make sure you
description over here so this is a SAM
file here and what the same file has is
basically what the fast queue file had
which is the sequence information as
well as that quality score information
but what it does add is key information
as how that read was Mac so I'd like to
point I'm not going to go over all of
the elements here but I go over some of
them that I think are a little more
relevant this right here is a mapping
quality score so it's basically how well
your wreath has met
to the reference another key information
element is the cigar string which is
right here so this basically gives you
an overview of how the reed has aligned
over the whole course of other reed
itself so in this case here this one's
simple one we have a hundred reeds that
have been met
a little bit this bottom one here you
can see that it's in a different
annotation you have fifty map reads and
then you have four 4700 base pair span
and would be indicating an intronic
region and then fifty wafers has been
met so in this one you can you can
decipher that the the beginning of this
Reed was mapped to one part of an exon
then there is split and then there's
another 50 Reed's that have been mapped
to the other portion of the exon itself
so a lot a lot more information is being
added into the Sam format for the
subsequent processes of variant clone so
that is the next process involved that
is varying poem so uses that first off
actually the Sam file is converted into
something called a BAM file so that BAM
file is the an identical copy to the Sam
file it has just been encoded in binary
format and indexed to make it accessible
to the computer so we take that that bam
file over and we run it through a very
important variant caller will just call
mismatches between the reference and the
actual read itself there are a variety
of different Bank rollers to see here
some of them are open source some of
them are not but all of them output a
file called the variant caller format so
the variant caller format looks like
this so you'll have a variety of
different headers which will give you
descriptions of some of the tags that
are included in the VCF itself so
usually what you'll have is some of the
common
we'll be chromosome I need position your
any ID for the actual snip itself so if
you have any RS numbers or anything on
that identifiers will be placed here
then you'll have your reference sequence
your reference read your reference base
art and then your alternate face right
here and then you have your quality
score and any filters that have been
placed in as a metric so if we take for
example let's take for example this
specific Smith here so in this specific
snip there are is a reference allele of
an A and then two different reference
rules that are attached to this RS
number and that's a cheat on the teeth
the quality here is 67 which is good and
that in the filter indicates that it's
passed so if you take a look at the one
above it the filter says q10 this is
because in this specific with the
specific variant we were only able to
get a quality score 4-3 so in this
filter parameters what they specified in
anything within 2 times X flag so let's
go back to the one that we were looking
at here and you'll get some of the tags
here so here is the number of specific
samples with actual data so samples that
actually have any of these snips would
be two samples here your depth and your
allelic frequency among other tags that
you can decipher from the headers up
here additionally you also have some
information related to each sample so if
you look here we have our genotype so
this genotype basically plays for this
specific sample we have a reference and
we have also have called both of these
alternate alleles here so we have two
different alternate alleles that have
been pulled through
also have the genotyping quality and we
have depth of sequencing so a lot of
information that helps you get as much
information as possible about the
variants you're calling and allow you to
infer on if they are actual real
variants or sequins and artifacts or
anything like that so I'd like to go
into the genotyping and baron-cohen for
HIV analysis workflow so this is just a
brief diagram of the processes so we
start with a fast to file here and we go
into the sequence QC where we generate
some of the information sparse run
throughput and our base quality so
that's that's off of a fast queue file
then we do mapping so we align to a
reference and then we do some refill
going then we take all those reads and
we assemble a context or con because it
can consensus sequence of all the reads
that has been generated we then do a
further alignment and generate a bam
file that bam file goes into the variant
calling software it generates that VCS
and we use that VCS parse data and
actually get information from the HIV
database we also do the genotyping as
well based off of the con fig that we
generated so go through all of this in
the next group of slides so
this is the sequence QC so these are
screenshots from our actual reporter
software which you'll see is you'll get
all your sample information and you'll
get the total bases total reads you'll
get the quality score for each base for
each each base of the read here and you
can come up in quantile charts over here
you'll also get information as to how
well the quality has been how well the
QC the quality scores have been for the
actual read itself right here and for
the cumulative run at a whole we also
get relink distributions over here as
well here we start mapping those reads
to a reference sequence so once once we
align all these reads to the reference
we need to filtering so we do several
rounds of filtering so our first round
of filtering actually is to filter out
any reads that weren't met so unmapped
reads our reads that haven't been mapped
to any other reference sequences that we
have in our database we then take a look
at the mapped reads here in map reads we
do a subsequent filtering based off of
where they've been aligned to so we have
nonspecific routes here so these are
reads that have not aligned to any of
the regions that we are looking for so
these regions can be we can look at it
at specific reads here so not specific
breeds our reads that haven't aligned to
either the control protease and RT &
integrase regions this card it reads our
read that have a length of less than 25
base pairs long or less than 25% of the
raid has aligned to any of the regions
now we're going to do assembly assembly
is basically the process of generating
that consensus sequence and creating
that contact that we're going to use for
genotyping before we do that we need to
down sample so our sequencing generally
usually typically produces about 5,000
to 15,000 x coverage if we were to use
all of those reads for the assembler it
would provide for a very slow process
and actually introduce errors so what we
do is we down sample to about 1,100 x
coverage for each reagent not Lagoon
only the down sample breeds are
assembled into this convict and we
generate two contexts one for the
protease and RT and one for the
integrates itself we filter out for
short and low coverage contexts so those
with a medium coverage of 250 base pairs
or less are filtered out and contexts
that are greater than 98% are merged so
this is variant calling alignment here
so what we essentially want to do is we
want to take the contexts that we've
generated and try to align them to the
reference genome so when we genotype
when we go for genotyping we're actually
going to align the context to over 4000
genotype references or in a database
we'll talk about that wound and Regina
coughing both what I wanted to get into
right now is actual pairing problem so
if any of you're familiar with oncology
what you normally do when you're running
variant calling is you're going to take
a reference sequence and you're going to
align the reads to that reference
sequence very simple for a very simple
process relatively simple process now if
you look here variant calling for viral
genomes is a little more complicated
from that because there is greater
variation
from strain to strain so if you notice
this example right here you see that
being reads don't quite aligned to this
reference sequence at the moment so what
do we do well we have another component
that we generated before and that was
for gene sizing which is the actual
content itself so our approach is to
actually take the content that has
already been aligned to these reads use
that contact as a Ginetta dénouement
locator for the reference once we found
the location that the spawn takes place
the only possible place that those reads
could align to is within that consume
those contiguous sequence so use that
context as a locator we call variants
directly off the reads after that point
so basically recreate we coordinate the
reads based off of the content itself
there's just a visualization plot off of
IG view that we that just shows our
approach versus the conventional
approach so if you look at the top here
we'll see all of these different colors
just anchored for a just different types
of variant calls here you can see
there's some spots here that are open
basically indicates that no reads were
aligned to these regions but when we use
the exact same when we use our approach
on the exact same data you'll actually
see that we have much higher coverage
and much better variant calling with our
approach so once we called the variants
we out put them on our reporter
interface here and what you get is a
very simple streamlined table with the
position your gene your amino acid
mutation variant frequency your coverage
reference coverage variant coverage with
p-values and also if you click this link
you get a visual look at your read depth
then we're going to take a look at
genotyping so what we do is we generate
a phylogenetic tree this is pre-built
and the database consists of over 4,000
48 reverse transcriptase integrase
regions and we do is we take that
contact and we actually blast that
contact over that database so we try to
find the closest hit out of that
database to our contiguous sequence so
by looking at the lowest common ancestor
here we can determine what type of
strain that the actual viral that the
sample is so this is just a little
overview of how the phylogenetic tree is
set up here and essentially anything
under the lowest common ancestors the
same genotype so we'll call that
that we have our reports so we have
three reports the first report is a QC
report so TC report will go over all the
sequencing information all the metrics
that need to pass in order to generate a
sufficient mgs1 so we have run quality
controls and sample quality controls and
within this we have different controls
that are four separate parts of our
workflow so we have a control that will
only apply to our extraction you have a
control that will multiply to sequencing
amplification and sequencing and then we
have controls that will control for the
whole process as well as variant column
as well so you'll have all the
information need to confidently provide
a report and know that your sequencing
has done has been done correctly the
next report that we use is the variant
calling before and the genotyping report
so this is essentially just another
subject in the page that I have showed
previously but with genotyping
information map so here you'll see that
we've generated to context of a sub-site
B we have an integration and a protease
and this is the meeting coverage for
both of those contexts we also have
target variants list which will give you
all the information you need for all the
banks that have been called the last
report is the drug resistance mutation
report so this report is actually
generated from the Stanford HIV database
or the two other databases that we have
in in this sections here so what
essentially what we do is we take the
VCF that has been generated and we send
that to either a local instance of HIV
BV or a online interest of HIV TB
depending on the customers preferences
from there this automated report gets
generated based off of all the these all
the VFC information that was submitted
so you'll get a report that has
information for the integration region
the protease region and the reverse
transcriptase region and will give you
susceptibility information for from
Stanford a n RS and the reddit databases
also with some comments about how these
variants confer resistance to be
specific
so just to recap here ng s is a fast and
accurate way to get genotyping and drug
resistance mutation information that
coupled with me Stanford HIV database is
a very concise resource that allows you
to get as much information as possible
and as much streamlined information as
possible for me to generate a report
that has drug resistance information
from that drug resistance information in
a concise and streamlined report for you
with that I'd like to send it over to
conduct well thank you on that I
appreciate that so today I'm going to
continue the theme of the variant
calling and cover cover a couple of
different topics regarding cancer
variants first we want to define the
different types of the cancer variants
seen in cancer second we want to talk
about the origins of these variants how
did they arise also I'm going to be
talking extensively about databases that
we use to collect and annotate these
variants also how do you know the
difference between a true variant as
opposed to an artifact of the processing
sometimes this can be difficult also
once you get a true list of variants how
do you classify them how do you report
them and to whom are you going to write
their report well
also cover how the annotation is done
and it is the annotation useful
predictive prognostic and diagnostic off
in the future someday we'll be able to
fix some of these problems variants and
patients and programs using a number of
biotechnology methods so NGS or next-gen
sequencing has truly revolutionized the
the pathology analysis September's NGS
sequencing of tumors since the first
time that we've been able to look at the
nucleus at the nucleotide level of
cancers from the variants we can
associate genes and from the genes we
can associate pathways to start to
understand the complex nature of and the
molecular biology of tumors DNA
sequencing analysis is not always used
as standalone diagnostics it's actually
part of a molecular toolbox that all of
the labs need to develop as NGS DNA
sequencing of multi-gene panels becomes
routine and standard for cancer samples
there must be an efficient routine
method for processing samples and for
classifying variants determining which
variants are biologically significant
for cancer maintenance and development
and which are not
is not always easy not even for the
experts fortunately unfortunately I
should say there is no agreed-upon
standards as to how to do this just yet
much of the work usually falls on to the
pathologist who must advise the
oncologist in recommending the tests to
order the amounts of tissue needed and
the budgets involved and will the tests
actually be relevant and useful to the
treatment of the patient
so there are a number of different
choices that the pathologist and the
oncologist must make and the first
decision is the type of NGS here were to
choose there are generally three main
categories of NGS testing they're shown
on the slide
cinque paddles whole exome and whole
genome genome panels
these include tens to thousands of genes
are the most popular currently because
they are designed to cover only the
genes of interest that relate to the
cancer genes there they may actually be
part of a pan-cancer in other words
covering all cancers or maybe a subset
may be two solid tumor cancers or they
may be very specific to an individual
tissue gene panels are the cheapest to
run and they have the high steps of
coverage they're also the easiest to
interpret whole exome testing is done at
several academic institutions but still
experimental the technical sequencing is
very good but we're just not sure of the
value added by covering all of the genes
at the nucleotide level the question is
is it worth the cost
whole genome testing is being done at a
few places but again like whole exome
the value is questionable compared to
the results as the cost of sequencing
and analysis drop and as the databases
get better whole exome and whole genome
will certainly be considered tests of
the future for routine testing gene
panels will dominate the market for the
time come and even if the gene panels
turn up negative there is always enough
time there usually is enough tissue to
actually generate another larger panel
remember you only need about 10
nanograms of FFPE DNA to run a gene gene
panel
so now I'd like to just go through a
couple of quick definitions genetic
variant these are alterations or genetic
differences in a patient compared to the
most common or reference DNA sequence
these can describe changes that are
benign pathogenic or of unknown
significance something called vu essence
or variants of unknown significance
variants can be of two different types
they can be normal non-pathogenic
genetic polymorphisms or they could be
pathological or pathogenic these are
changes or mutations that usually caused
frank disease and in our case cancer
these pathogenic variants can be divided
up into a number of different classes
single nucleotide polymorphisms or snips
make up about 90% of the variants seen
in the genome in cancer intragenic
insertions and deletions sometimes
called in Dells are often seen these can
be small to large also structural
variants SVS dot the landscape these can
be divided into two different types of
copy number changes as well as
chromosomal fusion or translocations
regulatory agencies have taken an
interest in this area the New York State
has published in NGS guidelines and goes
through the minimal requirements for
developing lab tests of different types
of variants this usually is about 10
positive controls or 10 retrospective
controls of a particular type of variant
the FDA have also held workshops for the
past few a few years about NGS and how
to define the variants they're very
concerned that the variants will be used
as companion diagnostics that are used
for decision making to treat cancers
specific drugs so very an analysis
really begins with the tissue of how
it's handled and processed in the
operating room and in the pathology lab
FFPE or formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue is the most common way tissues
process when working with DNA and RNA
samples it's important to use neutral pH
buffers that avoid aging the blocks more
than necessary as this will affect the
results
sspe can cause number of chemical
changes in DNA and also an RNA including
deamination oxidation cycling based
derivative formation and methylene
cross-linked formation in FFPE tissue
nucleotide transitions can occur so the
first step in ensuring robust variant
calling and cancer relies on accurate
base calling and alignment to the
reference assembly as Ovid described raw
sequence data from high-throughput
sequencers are moved through an analysis
analysis pipeline to call the bases
align them to the reference sequence
filter on quality and finally call the
variance Vella provides an end-to-end
instrument and bioinformatics pipeline
taking all of the different genetic
variants into account now the second
step once you have a list of variant
calls is to classify prioritize and
annotate them in cancer many of the labs
are sequencing both somatic cancer
tissue as well as individual as well as
an individual's your line or non cancer
genome this will give you a better
result as to the true somatic variants
as you will be able to subtract out your
inherited or germline variants the tumor
mass normal is always the best control
to determine which variants are germline
and which
somatically derived the problem is that
the sequencing of the germ line is a
quality check and not always reimbursed
so you have to you'll have twice the
cost and the value of doing this control
is still being debated if this were a
tumor only bioinformatics pipeline then
we would filter the variant list against
a list of normal or naturally occurring
variants in the non path energetic
population this is the germ line
filtering to remove the non pathogenic
variants and in this way we'll get a
better list to curate of pathogenic
variants if this were a reoccurring
tumor or a metastatic cancer then it
would be possible it might be possible
to go back and look at the previous
variants that were sequenced in the
primary tumor and this would be
important to understand why the tumor
progressed and if the tumor has
developed resistance mutations that
would affect the current treatment again
this is an area that continues to evolve
so to filter the germline variants we
take the entire variant list and we
match it to a database or databases of
normal variants which tell is the normal
non pathogenic variants that are
normally seen in the general population
here is a list of projects and databases
that have been used to filter germline
variants and decide which which of the
variants actually fall into the germline
or into the somatic class remember that
we as humans are all about 99.5%
identical to one another at the
nucleotide level but there are still
about ten to thirty million variants
that we differ at due to normal genetic
variation so there are a number of
professional societies and organizations
that have that have drawn up guidelines
and recommendations as to how to handle
genetic variance you see on the slide
there is the ACMG the American College
of medical genetics and genomics the IAR
see the International Agency for
research on cancer the AC or the amp EMP
Association for molecular pathology Capp
College of American Pathologists and
asking the American Society of Clinical
Oncology
these will these groups are working
together to make recommendations as to
the best practices in the industry and
poor healthcare so the amp and the ACMG
have gotten together and published joint
standards and guidelines for the
interpretation of sequence variants for
germline and inherited disease this was
actually the first of a number of
standards and guidelines paper this was
published in the genetics and medicine
journal and occurred early in 2015
subsequent to that guideline publication
the ACMG you went on to publish a list
of incidental findings or secondary
findings that should be considered
separately for clinical exome and genome
sequencing as patients may not want to
know their genetic status as to certain
genes for personal reasons this is the
most recent update which appeared in the
March 2017 issue of Journal of molecular
diagnostics
once we have filtered the germline
variants from the somatic variants we
now have a list that should be
considered cancer specific somatic
variants this list is usually long and
most of the variants are passenger
mutations in other words they're along
for the ride and don't contribute to any
pathology as such these variants are not
durable nor actionable in that they
contribute nothing to the overall
survival of the tumor the TCGA the
Cancer Genome Atlas is project from the
NCI NHGRI that has completed its work
but still releasing dead in the form of
papers and database submissions Civic
which stands for clinical interpretation
of variants and cancer is an expert
crowd-sourced knowledgebase from
Washington University describing
therapeutic prognostic diagnostic and
predisposing relevance of inherited and
somatic variants of all types there are
now databases that coordinate the
variant gene pathway information and now
related to relevant drugs the drug gene
interaction database at Washington
University and the pharmacogenomics
knowledge base farm GK B at Stanford
University are two such databases
currently there are 402 potentially
druggable genes listed in the DTI
database one result that came out of the
TCGA sequencing project was that
different cancers have different
mutation rates this analysis from the
road shows a significant difference
between melanoma and lung cancers shown
on the right hand side compared to
inherited disease shown on the left hand
side of the ground this observation
could have implications quin treating
patience with the new immuno checkpoint
inhibitors with regards to cancer
testing several professional
organizations have established standards
and guidelines to follow in December of
2016 cap amp and s code issue joint
guidelines for the standardization
interpretation and recording of sequence
variants in cancer this was published in
the Journal of molecular diagnostics
this report authored by Marilyn Lee
makes recommendation to pathologists and
oncologists that assess the status of
NGS based cancer tests and establishing
standard classifications annotations
interpretations and reporting
conventions for somatic sequence
variants these guidelines prioritize the
variants into actionable variants that
are classified by being therapeutic
prognostic or diagnostic also recently
published by amp and cap was the best
practice guidelines for next-generation
sequencing based on ecology panel
validation this was also published in
the Journal of molecular diagnostics the
ASCO amp cap joint guideline system
contains four tiers to categorize
somatic mutation variants by clinical
significance these are based on
diagnostic prognostic and/or therapeutic
value tier 1 is our variants with strong
clinical significance tier 2 are
variants with potential clinical
significance tier 3 are variants with
unknown clinical significance tier 4 are
variants be deemed benign or likely
benign you can actually see that tier 1
and tier 2 are broken down into two more
levels a and B for greater resolution
lots of things are changing in the
sequencing world and variant calling is
no different there is a lot of new
information about mutated genes pathways
variants and the drugs to treat them
with there's also valuable information
with regards to dosing routes of
administration and outcome no one can be
expected to know or to recall all of
this information there is the promise of
artificial intelligence AI and machine
learning coming along to be able to help
to make sure that the variant calls and
the drugs assigned are the best possible
choices for each patient
I cages is a bioinformatics tool from
Columbia University that prioritizes and
classifies cancer driver genes for a
more personalized result IBM Watson is a
similar tool to help clinicians
understand all of the data involved in
clinical sequencing and precision
oncology obviously there's a lot of work
that is involved in taking the raw
sequencing data filtering it down into
the correct variants and annotating them
properly vela now offers an informatics
surface that takes the raw data files
and maps the sequences it filters all of
bad reads out and then compares the
variants to 46 gene and sequence
databases that are available these
represent all of the somatic mutations
found in 822 cancer associated genes it
also pulls the information from over
200,000 clinical trials that are going
on in the world today to do clinical
trial matching
Bella then takes this data and
summarizes it into an easy to read easy
to understand clinical report called
therapy this tells the doctor what he
needs to know what is actionable and
what is druggable in the near future
researchers are working on ways to
detect tumor variance from normal blood
draws this type of testing will identify
somatic variants for screening and poor
residual disease and will give the
oncologists and early heads-up on cancer
screening a number of companies
including Villa have cell-free DNA kits
and extraction methods to isolate in
sequence cell free DNA and finally in
the not so near future scientists are
working on a number of DNA manipulation
manipulations and cellular targeting
methods that will potentially modify the
DNA of the patient and treat the patient
at the germline level zinc fingers
talons and more recently cast CRISPR
technologies could all be used for this
purpose
so to summarize there are new joint
guidelines and standards that have been
recently published by professional
organizations these guidelines recommend
tier based somatic variant
categorization and reporting informatics
can and should be automated variant
prioritization can assist in the
interpretation and reporting but final
manual curation should still be done
development of variant pipeline analysis
requires careful review of variants and
an understanding of the limitations of
the current sequence databases and
finally Vela has developed
hardware solutions and software
solutions to solve NGS
cancer testing problems and with that
I'd like to turn it back to Susie
thank you so much for that wonderful
presentation dr. Carmack and docume mood
we want to get right to the questions so
here's a reminder to the audience
members how they can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left of your screen
if you are unable to get to your
questions due to time constraints dr.
Carmack and dr. Mahmood will be
answering submitted questions via email
so let's begin with our first question
this question is for you dr. Mahmood how
important is it to analyze the integrase
gene for HIV drm i think it's very
important it's just as important as
analyzing the protease or reverse
transcriptase regions specifically
because there are integrase inhibitor
drugs that are being developed to target
the specific region so things like lvl
fatigue Revere and while Tegra veer
specifically are these drugs are
specifically targeting the integrase
gene itself so in order for you to
properly diagnose a scenario where you
know you are going to prescribe this
specific film the drug to a to a patient
you would essentially need to be able to
know whether they have any mutations or
DRMs in there in that viral strain that
would pose some resistance to that drill
thank you so much for that dr. Mahmood
we actually have another question from
you for you from an audience member how
is bioinformatics development different
for use in the analysis of viral RNA
versus let's say human DNA okay so I
think we touched on it a little bit with
with the presentation the viral genome
is much less complicated relative to
some degree versus the actual human
genome itself but what it would it make
what's less complicated about it
complicates it even more if that makes
any sense the genetic variation from
stranger strain makes it much more
difficult to actually sequence and
perform a alignment and variant column
on it
so usually what you end up having to do
is you cannot do any of as far as
targeted primer sequencing you can't
really do that with a viral genome
because of the variation you'll have you
will tend to have snips under primers
and if you have primers that are
amplifying all these specific regions
that you're targeting or the hot spots
at your parting you could be targeting
at so for HIV to be over 300 variants
and those parents will well you might
have 80 90 primers something like that
you're bound to have some snips under
those primers that might drop out we
need both sequences themselves so what
we end up having to apply is sort of a
whole genome shotgun sequencing approach
to a relatively small genome so you
might have something that along the
lines of you know regions that might be
about a thousand base pairs long but you
have to apply this whole genome approach
to those to the sort of viral genomes in
order for you to actually be able to get
robust and efficient sequencing data out
of it
thank you sir for those answers this
next question is for your colleague dr.
Carmack how do curators weigh the
various pieces of information found in
literature for variants and make a
determination of the importance of that
mutation it's actually a very good
question probably the the best way to
answer that is with experience and also
curating going through all of the
databases and understanding you know
with the with the guidelines of the the
professional organizations are but it
really just takes experience and looking
at outcome data that cumulates over time
so this is again one of those areas that
continues to to progress thank you we
have one more for you dr. Carmack are
there limitations to the cell-free DNA
kits currently on the market for variant
identifications and loes your company be
putting out a product in this arena you
will be putting out a product in this
area again this is one of those research
areas that continues to expand some of
the technical problems with cell-free
DNA of courses getting the background
down so that it is economically feasible
to be able to sequence just the
cell-free or the DNA from the tumor so
identification of the tumor from
normally release cell free DNA is still
an issue there are some technologies
methods to actually lower the background
or to actually amplify the the
biomarkers
are needed it always helps if you know
the biomarkers that you're looking for
in other words if the person has a
leukemia or a biomarker that is a
signature for the disease to be able to
look for one or two variants rather than
a whole slew of variants thank you
gentlemen for those wonderful answers to
those questions and thank you so much
for your presentation I'd also like to
thank labret today for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
for up to six months keep an eye out for
an email from laborat
alerting you with this webcast and look
how it will be able to be replayed we
encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
so much for joining us again we hope to
see you next time goodbye